[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
FOX BUTTERFIELD:
Thank you, David.
Am I audible?
AUDIENCE: Go ahead.
FOX BUTTERFIELD: OK.
So I'm going to talk
about my new book, which
was just published, called,
"In My Father's House."
And I have to say
something about the origins
of the book, which emerged
from a series of seemingly very
dry, academic studies that
were unknown to the public.
And these showed
that crime tends
to run very heavily in families.
These multi-year
studies were conducted
in Philadelphia, Pittsburgh,
Rochester, Denver,
and, most recently, Chicago
in the United States
and in London in the UK.
What they found was
astonishing because the results
in each of these cities over
a very long period of time,
over more than 50 years--
they found that 5% of families
account for half of all crime.
And 10% of families account
for 2/3 of all crime.
And whichever city you looked at
over whichever period of time,
the same result came back.
And I just say it again because
it was astonishing to me
that 5% of families are
responsible for half
of all crime.
And 10% of families
are responsible for 2/3
of all crime.
This intergenerational
transfer of violence,
as criminologists
like to refer to it,
was first documented
in a separate,
but, similar, study
done in Boston
in the 1940s, which looked at
a sample of 500 delinquent boys
from working class homes.
The study found that 2/3 of
the boys sentenced by a judge
to a reformatory had a
father who had been arrested,
convicted, and sent to prison.
And half of the boys
had a grandfather
who had been arrested
and sent to prison.
And half of the boys
also had a mother
who had been arrested
and sent to prison.
Equally striking, all
of the delinquent boys
in the Boston study were white.
In part, this racial
makeup is a reminder
that until the 1960s, at least,
until after the Second Great
Migration of blacks from the
South during and after World
War II, most crime
in the United States,
including violent crime,
was committed by whites.
So when we think back
on our famous criminals,
we think back to Jesse James
in the 19th century in Missouri
or Al Capone in
Prohibition Era-Chicago,
or Bonnie and Clyde in
Texas during the Depression.
The common and pernicious
American stereotype today
of young black predators
with guns dealing drugs
is really a creation
of the last 30 years.
While it is true that blacks are
overrepresented in prison, they
still--
I should say that whites
still commit the majority
of all crimes in the US.
Despite this
statistical evidence
of the role of family
in crime, criminologists
have largely neglected
this line of causality,
instead looking at such
well-known risk factors
as bad neighborhoods, poverty,
deviant peers at school,
drugs, or gangs.
These are real
issues, of course.
But chronologically,
a child's life
begins at home with his
or her own family long
before the neighborhoods
or friends or classmates
have an influence on them.
John Laub, who is one of
our leading criminologists
at the University
of Maryland, has
written that
scholars have largely
avoided focusing on the
families because that would tend
to suggest that there
is a biological or even
genetic basis for
crime, which could get
the criminologists
who said something
like that labeled as a racist.
Because these studies were so
little known by the public,
to me they represented an
opportunity during 15 years
that I wrote about crime
and criminal justice
for "The New York Times."
I wanted to try to
find a white family
with a large number of members
who had been sent to prison,
both as a way to
refocus on the family
and as a way to try to
disentangle race from crime.
By happenstance, an official
of the Oregon Department
of Corrections told me
that he had a family
that he thought had six members,
a white family that he had
six members who were in prison.
And he offered to
let me interview
the members of the family in
prison if I came to Oregon.
At that time, I was
living in Boston.
But I was intrigued
by the family.
And I went out and,
little did I know
that after 10 years of
working on this project,
I would find that the
real total of members
of the family in
prison was not 6.
It's 6-0, 60 members over four
generations of this family
known as the Bogles.
And the Bogles had
a story to tell,
how criminals often grow
up in criminal families.
What you are raised
with, you grow to become,
Tracey Bogle told me.
He was the first of the men
that I talked to in prison.
He was serving a
16-year sentence
for a crime that
involved kidnapping,
armed robbery, aggravated
assault, car theft, and sodomy.
He'd committed the crime with
his older brother, Bobby Bogle.
In my first interview
with Tracey,
he unintentionally handed
me the theme of the book.
He said if I'd been raised
in a family of doctors,
I'd be a doctor today.
But I was raised in
a family of outlaws.
And the only law
we knew were cops
coming to break down our
doors, coming to arrest us
or to send us to jail.
Tracey's story, in some
ways, was a familiar story
about the power of
imitation among children,
imitation of their parents or
their older brothers or sisters
or grandparents.
Doctors, we know,
often have children
who grew up to become doctors.
Lawyers have children who
grow up to become lawyers.
For the Bogles, it was a
story about family values,
although not just
the family values
we normally mean when we talk
about family values being good.
The Bogle criminal
pater familias,
as Bobby and Tracey
told their stories,
was their father, who is
known as Rooster Bogle.
Rooster was a short man with
large protruding ears and dark,
curly hair, and a nasty temper.
He was not the most-violent
member of the family.
That distinction belonged
to his eldest son, Tony,
who with his wife, Paula, were
convicted of murder in Tucson,
Arizona, where Tony is serving
a life sentence in prison.
But Rooster was the most
malignant member of the family,
spreading what his boys
came to call the family
curse like a criminal
contagion, which
infected almost everyone in the
family over four generations.
As Bobby told me, Rooster
hated toys and sports.
The only thing fun
for him was stealing.
So he took us out with him
to burglarize our neighbors'
houses or steal their
cows or chickens
or take their mail out of
their mailbox, particularly
Social Security checks
if they could find them.
And one night Rooster
led his whole clan
to the big Bonneville
Dam on the Columbia River
and broke into
the fish hatchery.
They took as many coho
and Chinook salmon
as they could load
into Rooster's truck.
Their mother, Kathy,
served as the lookout,
waiting in the truck while
they were inside the wire.
And then she drove
the getaway vehicle.
So it was a burglary
by the whole family.
Rooster also did not
believe in celebrating
Christmas or birthdays.
And years later, while
he was incarcerated
in the Oregon State
Penitentiary in Salem,
Bobby could remember
only one Christmas
when his father gave
him a Christmas present.
It was a heavy, metal wrench
in a plain, brown paper bag
presented with no explanation.
Bobby was only four
years old at the time.
And he was a little stumped
as to what this was.
But then he recalled what he'd
heard around the family dinner
table in excited conversations,
his father boasting
about the burglaries that
he'd done when he was younger.
So Bobby decided that his father
had given him a burglar's tool.
And the next morning,
which was actually
Christmas Day, he snuck out
of the house before dawn
and with his older
brother, Tony,
broke into a nearby
grocery store.
In the back of a store,
there was a caged-in area
with a padlock on it
where all the Coca-Cola
bottles were stashed.
And Bobby used this
great, big wrench
to break open the padlock
and got the Coca-Cola bottles
and took them home with him
to have a family celebration.
When he walked in the
door with all the bottles,
Rooster was elated.
He said, yes, that's my boys.
It was as if he was
celebrating a school report
card with straight A's or a
Little League baseball home
run.
Bobby told me, my
father had been
encouraging us to steal
practically since I was born.
He taught us stealing
was good as long as we
didn't get caught.
If the boys got caught, Rooster
would cut a switch off a tree
and use the branch to whip the
boys until their backs and legs
were covered with blood.
So, Bobby said, we were a crime
family, where stealing was fun
and going to prison
was the honorable thing
to do for your family.
One of the happiest
moments of Tracey's life
occurred when he
was eight years old.
And he and Bobby managed to
break into the attic of a bar
one evening and
snuck up the stairs
and waited till after
dark when the bar
had closed and then went
back down the stairs
into the darkened room.
And they helped
themselves to all the cash
in the cash register.
They stuffed it in a
bag and walked home
to where they were sharing
with their mother, which
was a trailer.
And while their mother was still
sleeping early in the morning,
they took the sack
of cash and poured it
over her head,
which woke her up.
And she shrieked with joy.
That made Tracey very happy.
And when he told the story
to me in prison about that,
he was so happy, the tears
began to run down his cheeks.
And he began to shake.
It was as if, in recalling
this robbery, that he
was able to transport
himself over the high walls
of the prison, in fact,
transport himself back in time
to that very moment in his
mother's mobile home years
before.
Rooster not only took his
children out to commit crimes,
he also happily prophesied
where that would lead them.
Some days, he would take his
boys to a lake to go fishing.
The route would take them
past another prison outside
of Salem, Oregon State
Correctional Institution
at Salem, which is surrounded
by mounds of shiny, razor wire.
Rooster would gaze
at the prison,
as if he was looking
at some ancient castle.
And he would say to his
boys, look carefully.
Remember this because
when you grow up,
this is where you're
going to live.
In fact, as Rooster's
seven sons grew older,
they all dropped out of school.
Bobby left in the seventh grade,
Tracey in the eighth grade.
And instead of attending
conventional commencement
ceremonies, they graduated
to more serious crime.
Their favorite as teenagers
was to steal big rig trucks, 18
wheelers, which they
would drive down
I-5 from Salem and
the Willamette Valley
to California, over 300 miles,
or east to Boise, Idaho,
on I-84, more than 450 miles.
When they started
these capers, Tracey
was so young and short
that he could barely
see over the steering wheel.
And his feet hardly
touched the pedals.
He was seven.
Altogether, the boys claim
to me that they stole
more than 300 big rig trucks.
Of course, you'd want to allow
for some youthful braggadocio
in this.
But the number was still large.
And the boys were eventually
caught and arrested
and sentenced to the most-secure
juvenile reformatory in Oregon.
Please allow me a flashback
here because the Bogles' story
actually starts much
earlier than Rooster.
I was able to trace
the family back
to the end of the Civil
War in 1865 in Tennessee
to a tiny farming
hamlet called Daylight
in the hills of Tennessee,
central Tennessee,
near Nashville.
Rooster's ancestors,
it turns out,
were poor farmers and
con men, grifters,
who tried for years to
trick the federal government
in Washington into giving
Roosters great grandfather
a Civil War pension.
He claimed that he had
been a captain in the Union
Army, which he was not.
He wasn't even in
the Army at all.
But they kept trying until the
beginning of the first World
War in 1914.
So like 40 years, they
kept filing false petitions
to the government.
And Rooster's own
father, Lewis Bogle,
continued the family
tradition of being
a con artist when he moved from
Tennessee to Texas in 1921.
He joined his uncle there, who
came from Daylight, Tennessee,
selling the local
specialty, which
was nursery trees stock,
young apple and pear trees.
His uncle had made a small
fortune with this business
and had been able to purchase
a house and a new Model T Ford,
which is the symbol of the
Automobile Age, which had just
arrived in the US.
Lewis soon fell in love
with a local country girl,
named Elvie Morris.
And he conned her
into believing that he
was the real owner of the
Model T Ford and of the house.
And she was so smitten
by this, seeing this man
with apparently good prospects,
that she married him.
But then the local economy
fell into a depression
because the price
of cotton dropped.
And so Lewis's uncle decided
to move back to Tennessee.
And in the process,
he sold his house
and took the Model
T Ford with him.
And Lewis was
exposed as a fraud.
Luckily, his new wife came to
the rescue because as a girl,
she had learned how to
drive a motorcycle, which
young women in Texas, in those
days, did not consider polite.
With her motorcycle
skills, she went out
and found a carnival, which
was traveling through.
And they needed somebody to
drive a motorcycle around,
what's called, a motor drum.
I don't know if any of you know
what a motor drum is, where you
drive around the walls and
go up and up, and up and up
to the top.
And then, the person
driving the motorcycle
will raise one hand up.
And the customers
leaning over the top
would drop money
into their hands.
Sorry.
Elvie and Lewis, in fact,
spent the next 20 years
working in the carnival,
which was, largely--
The people that they worked
with were largely gypsies.
And they barely
eked out a living.
But they supplemented it
by making and then selling
moonshine during prohibition.
And they sometimes got
arrested and went to prison.
They lived in railroad cars or
tents, moving from town to town
each week as the
carnival moved on.
So there was no time
or place, really,
for their children
to go to school.
So most of their children
grew up almost illiterate.
Rooster was the last child.
And in 1958, when he was
16, he joined his brothers
and his sister and his mother in
burglarizing their neighborhood
grocery store.
They were then living
in Amarillo, Texas.
And the burglary was the largest
in the history of Amarillo,
up to that point.
They made off with $20,000
from the grocery store.
And Elvie sat at the dining room
table, as they tell the story.
And she had all the money.
And she would put
bills out in front
of each of the members
of the family who
had taken part, as if she
was dealing a deck of cards.
But two months later, the
police solved the crime.
They arrested the Bogles.
And Rooster was sentenced
to five years in the state
penitentiary in Huntsville.
It was only after all the
boys finally got out of prison
and came home that their
father and mother decided
they should move away from
Amarillo because police
were picking them up anytime
there was something suspicious.
So they tried moving
to Oregon, to Salem.
But that did not stop their
criminal proclivities, which
they simply brought with them.
Even now, 60 years
after that, there
are still 10 Bogles
in prison and three
who have escaped and
are hiding somewhere
in Montana and Arizona.
One criminologist
estimated the costs
of a family like the
Bogles to society
that the Bogle family
by itself would
have cost other Americans
a total of $480 million,
rather staggering figure.
Finally, I'd like
to share a few ideas
on what the Bogles and the
research on how crime runs
in families might tell us about
reforming our criminal justice
system.
One of the oddities about
the criminal justice system
is that, although we
spent $282 billion
on the criminal justice
system last year,
the criminal justice
system does not keep data
on families like the Bogles.
That is, when
somebody is arrested,
the police don't
ask them, do you
have a father or a
mother or brother
or sister or children
who have been in prison?
When somebody goes to court,
the prosecutor and the judge
don't ask, do you have
anybody in your family
who's ever been to prison?
If a person is convicted
and sent to prison,
when they arrive in prison,
the prison doesn't ask them,
do you have a mother or
father who's been in prison
or an aunt or an
uncle or grandparent
or children who've
been in prison?
So nobody really knows
exactly how many children
there are like this.
One way a
family-focused approach
could make the criminal
justice system more effective
is if we gather data on this.
I don't mean to
stigmatize the Bogles
but it's rather to
help them by trying
to get them therapy
at an early age
when they're more
easily reached.
It might sound intrusive.
But it could be as
simple as an intake form
that you fill out when you go to
visit your doctor or hospital.
And they ask you, do you have a
family history of heart attack
or strokes or
diabetes or cancer.
And we all pretty much are
accustomed to answering
those questions.
And it helps because that
can play a vital role
in whether you're likely
to get the condition too.
And it's very similar.
Criminality is passed
down in a very similar way
we know because the
statistics I was talking about
show that the more
members of your family
you have who have been
convicted and sent to prison,
the more likely you are
to go to prison yourself.
So it's similar to
what happens medically.
Second, a family
focus could lead
to more therapies
or better therapies
for young people who are in
danger of becoming delinquent.
For example, in
recent years, there's
a new program called
multisystemic therapy, which
uses highly trained
psychologists or social workers
to go into the
homes of people who
have a child or a
teenager who's getting
in trouble with the law.
And the program can be
triggered by the youngster
appearing before a judge,
who decides to send them
to this therapy, rather
than sending them
to a locked institution.
The program will bring this team
of specially trained therapists
right into the home and
actually often set up shop there
and live there with the family.
The trick is to try to get the
whole family, not just the one
kid whose getting in trouble,
but to learn about the father,
the mother, the brothers,
the sisters, grandparents,
if they can be found,
if they're around.
And multisystemic therapy
has treated 200,000 families
over the past 10
years in 35 states
and 25 foreign countries.
And the early results
are very encouraging.
There's also another way to
use a focus on the family
to reduce crime.
The judge who presided over
many of the Bogles' trials
over four generations
was named Albin Norblad.
He was a crusty
law-and-order Republican,
who favored a lock them up and
throw away the key approach.
But over years of
dealing with the Bogles,
he told me, when the courts
try to deal with families
like these, we always lose.
He said, just locking
up more Bogles
is not going to do anything
more than cost taxpayers' money.
He said we need another
solution to this.
He didn't know that at the time.
But a few things have
emerged since then.
And one program came
about by accident
after Hurricane
Katrina obliterated New
Orleans in 2005.
A young criminologist at
the University of Texas
noticed something fascinating
because most state inmates
in Louisiana, in the prisons,
come from New Orleans.
After Katrina, they
couldn't go back home
because their houses were gone.
So they began moving to Texas.
And this criminologist
began to survey them
at one- and three- and
five-year intervals
after Katrina to see if their
rate of recommitting crimes
would go down or
would stay the same.
And what he found was that
the ones who moved away
had a much lower rate of
recommitting crime and being
sent back to prison,
compared to those
who had managed to go back to
their homes in New Orleans.
What he concluded was
that by moving away,
these people had been
able to, former inmates,
had been able to break
their social network.
And so they were able to
get away from the habits
that they had learned
with their families.
And this young criminologist,
named David Kirk,
then created a
program in Maryland,
using funds from the Maryland
Department of Corrections,
for inmates who are being
released from prison
whose homes were in Baltimore.
Baltimore dominates prison
population in Maryland.
And they worked out a program,
under which the state would
give inmates who agreed
not to go home to Baltimore
but would move to other
parts of Maryland--
It would give them a housing
allowance of $1,200 a month.
And quite a few of the inmates
have taken the state's offer
and have not moved back to
their homes in Baltimore
but moved away to other
places, taking housing loans.
And the rate of re-offending
for those people
has really plummeted.
And it's one of the few
actually successful programs
that anyone can identify.
I'm also very happy
to tell you that,
because it took me so long,
10 years, to write this book,
to get all the Bogles to
talk, that, finally last year,
the first member of the family
ever in 150 years, actually
graduated from college.
Her name is Ashley Bogle.
And she was a
granddaughter of Rooster.
She decided that she didn't want
to be like the other members
of her family.
And she was very good in school.
And she got straight A's all the
way through high school and all
the way through college.
And she's now got a job
helping work with computers--
I can't tell you exactly what--
in a hospital right
outside of Salem.
She's bought herself
a small apartment.
She has a car.
And she has a
three-year-old daughter, who
she's raising as a single mom.
So she has finally
managed to get past this.
And every day when she
commutes to the hospital,
from her home to the
hospital where she works,
she has to pass right by the
Oregon State Correctional
Institution, where many of her
family members were locked up.
In fact, she still has a cousin,
who is exactly her age, who's
inside that prison.
But she doesn't dwell on
this bizarre coincidence
because she has been
able to move past it.
She no longer needs to live
with crime, with violence,
or with prison in her life.
So I'd like to stop there
and invite any of you who
have questions, please.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
So you mentioned
different solutions
to help the Bogles and
everyone in their situation.
The first one,
here at Google, we
have this policy where we always
think that more data is better.
So you mentioned people
should have, maybe,
list that their parents
or their immediate family
went to prison.
But don't you think there
could be bias introduced
if the jury or the
judge knows that person
comes from a family of crime?
FOX BUTTERFIELD: I'm glad you
asked that because I had--
I wanted to make a
comment about that.
So, yes, I mean, this
is a balancing act.
The judge will know.
The prosecutors will
know if the person
themself had a prior record.
But now we're getting
to the question
of if some member of their
family had a prior record.
It's a balancing act.
And I don't know the answer.
But, actually, I was thinking
that maybe Google would
have an answer as to how you get
this data because it's actually
available.
Every state and every
city has a record
of people who are
sentenced to prison.
And they have it.
It's on your computer
anytime you want to look,
whether you're in Arizona
or Texas or California
or Washington or Oregon.
You can easily find it.
So it's a question of
collecting that data
and putting it somewhere.
I don't know the answers
to how you balance that.
But the benefit would be
that you could stop more
of the members of this family.
If the Bogles had
been known for--
they'd been publicly
or at least known
to the authorities for
what they were doing
for all the time that
passed, the opportunities
were lost to try to change them.
But nobody could do it because
they didn't fully know.
So the judge who told me--
Well, this judge
named Albin Norblad,
he said that he'd had five
families like the Bogles
in his court, all of whom had
more than 50 members in prison
covering four generations.
And he was just one
to throw his hands up
because he had very little
he could do about them.
But if they'd been
seen earlier, they
could've been, some way,
headed away from this.
I don't know the correct
answer to your question.
But I think it's something
we have to think about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So in
your talk you talked
about a lot of the
socialization that happened,
about how the child was
given the wrench when
they were really young, went
off and stole all these colas,
about how somebody was talking
about this criminal act
and it brought tears to
their eyes and so on.
So how does bringing a
whole bunch of people
into that family
and having that--
You mentioned that it's
one of the solutions,
having these people
come into the family.
How does that help with
the whole socialization
and glorification of
crime that they already
have in their family?
Does that make sense?
FOX BUTTERFIELD: Yes, of
course, it makes sense.
It's a good question.
I think the one program
that I mentioned--
There are several
others very similar now,
which are actually
now companies that are
in the business of doing this.
They're multisystemic
therapy actually
has its headquarters in
Charleston, South Carolina.
There's a similar company
based in New York.
But they're, basically now,
all around the country.
And they work to try to find
the most positive person
in the family, whoever it is.
Doesn't matter whether it's
a grandparent or cousin.
And then they try to get
the family member who's
most in trouble and
attach relations
between the most positive person
and the person most in trouble
and try to see if they can
get some benefit from closer
relationship between
those two extremes.
But they also work
with the whole family.
And I saw one program in
Jacksonville, Florida, which
was quite interesting
because the local prosecutor
there, when kids were
starting to get in trouble,
he had hired--
Instead of hiring
another prosecutor,
he'd actually hired
a psychologist.
And the psychologist devised
a series of weekly meetings.
If there was a kid getting
in serious trouble--
For example, I saw a boy
who was five years old who
had hit a girl--
a boy who had hit
a girl, also five--
over the head with a brick
and fractured her skull.
Normally, the boy
would have been
taken in front of a
juvenile court judge
and sent to some locked
juvenile facility,
even though he was
only five years old.
But, in this case, the
prosecutor had set up a team.
And what they did was they
brought together people
from all different agencies.
So they had somebody
from the police, somebody
from a local parole
and probation.
They had somebody from
the school department.
They had somebody from the
hospital where each of the kids
was born.
And they sat around a table.
And they would go around
the table asking questions.
What do you know about this kid?
And police would know this much.
And the parole officer would
know another part of it.
And then the hospital
would find out more.
For example, this
particular kid was--
His mother was a
cocaine addict and had
been born addicted to cocaine.
And the school would
tell them other stories.
So by the time they'd
gone around the table,
they had learned a great
deal more about the kid.
And they were able to figure
out ways of dealing with him.
And in Jacksonville
what they did was--
Because Jacksonville's a large
military base and has a large,
retired military population--
It has Air Force and Navy bases.
So they get volunteers and they
assign them, the volunteers,
to work with these kids,
actually be there in the house.
So they will be there when the
kid gets up in the morning,
make sure he or
she gets breakfast,
then will walk with
them to school,
and then be there when they get
out of school, bring them home.
If they have
homework to do, make
sure the homework gets done.
Make sure they have a
proper dinner that night.
And, in some cases, what
the prosecutor would do is,
he would say the
mother or the father
have to sign a civil contract.
He can't force the family
to take the therapy.
But if they sign a civil
contract, that's enforceable.
And then, the kid will be in
that program for maybe two
years.
And then, in the case that I'm
talking about, where the boy--
whose name was Freddie--
broke the girl's
skull with a brick,
he had this mentor in
this life for two years.
And that's now more
than 10 years ago.
And he's had no further
juvenile record.
Being able to figure out
what was wrong with him,
understand what he--
I should have said
that they also
then discovered that
the actual father was
in prison for murder.
But only by pooling
all these resources
were they able to establish
what the family was like
and what influence they
might have had on the kid.
And then you bring in the mentor
who forms this positive role
model that the kid
didn't otherwise have.
So that particular case and
the Jacksonville case, a lot
of good stuff has happened.
And it doesn't cost much money.
The volunteers are free.
And it certainly costs a lot
less than locking a kid up,
which could be $35,000--
$50,000 a year,
even though they're
only five years old.
AUDIENCE: Following up on this.
So it sounds like
the problem is when
people start doing crime with
young age, it's fun and profit.
And they don't get punished.
That grows.
So they get more fun
and profit, until they
commit something serious,
get once caught, and then
go to prison.
So would it help to try to
correct them at earlier age,
to kind of try to catch
for the small crimes
and punish them someway or
work with them, like you say,
therapy.
But therapy's just different
word for prison, just milder
prison.
FOX BUTTERFIELD: I'm not sure I
would agree that the therapy is
a milder form of prison.
I mean, the therapy
properly done can be very--
is proved very beneficial
in these cases from the ones
that I've looked at and
spent some time with.
And the juvenile prisons
are wretched places.
And they very seldom have much
positive impact on the kid.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
many of these programs
would be most effective if
the people want to change,
want to get out of
this life of crime.
In how many of your
interviews did you
find that people did
want to get out of it.
And how often was it?
Were people satisfied with
the current situation?
FOX BUTTERFIELD:
That's a good question.
So in the Bogle family,
very few of the people
really wanted to get out of
it because this is the values
that they had learned.
And their value system
was, to the rest of us,
looks kind of upside down.
And it was, in fact, when
they got out of prison
that they found it
very difficult to cope
with the world because,
in prison, they
were used to having
everything free and available.
I mean, your housing was free.
Your food was free.
You didn't have to pay taxes.
You didn't have to obey
the law, particularly.
So you were able to
do what you wanted.
I was able to spend time with
one of the Bogles, Tracey
Bogle, when he finally got--
finished his 16-year prison
sentence.
Everybody else in his
family was in prison.
And nobody could go and
pick him up when he got out.
So I went.
And I spent the next
two weeks with him,
watching what he had to
do and all the places
he had to register and sign up
and what programs he had to do.
He found it incredibly hard
to go straight, although he
said to me, the key words.
He said, this just
isn't any fun.
It was much easier
committing crimes.
And so he went back.
And he began
committing crimes again
because that was
what he like to do.
And living the regular law and
order life just wasn't any fun.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
share some numbers
about how many families
like this that you
were able to encounter?
FOX BUTTERFIELD: Well, so
this was sort of the big one
that I encountered.
After I started
work on this family,
I didn't go looking for others.
But there were many other
branches of this family
that I also looked at.
So there was another branch
like Rooster's, which
I did the research on them for
over a long period of time.
But it was just too much
to put into the book.
And the stories became
very repetitive.
They sounded a lot
like each other.
So my book editor said, you just
can't put them all in the book.
So I threw away more
than half my research.
I mean, painful for me but
it made the book a lot easier
to read.
My editor was right about that.
But once I found
the Bogles, I mean,
I heard about other families.
But it was just impossible
to spend that much time doing
another family.
AUDIENCE: So earlier
you said that it
seemed like some of
the family members
were totally fine
with the arrangement
and the way things were
going in their family.
Did you get the impression that,
if at the end of the sentence
they were offered the chance
to just stay in prison,
that they would have taken it?
FOX BUTTERFIELD: No.
I did meet one
person who actually
did that, who was
released from prison
but refused to leave
because he was actually
worried that when he got
out, he would screw up again.
And he would commit more crimes.
And he'd have to
go back to prison.
And he stayed in prison
several extra years
when he didn't have to.
So, I mean, that does happen.
But I'd say most people
when they're let out,
they want to get out.
But then they find that life
outside is really much more
difficult. It's hard
to pay your bills
for your house and your
food and pay your taxes,
so taxes, not something they
ever had to worry about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I was
wondering if you
had an opinion
about alternatives
to prison, from just
community work, all
the way to the penal
abolition movement that
is kind of on the fringe.
But it exists.
There are people who argue
for the complete abolition
of anything penal and
process everything
through civil courts.
FOX BUTTERFIELD:
So you're asking
about what are the alternatives
that exist instead of prison?
AUDIENCE: And more about your
opinion about, well, what--
If you were to set the
policy, where should we go?
FOX BUTTERFIELD: So
I would certainly
want to have many more
alternatives than we have now
and particularly for younger
people who are starting
to get in trouble with the law.
We want to try to
divert them from this.
But the criminal justice
system in the United States
is set up to hit people pretty
hard as soon as you can.
So they get very long sentences.
American sentencing laws
are much tougher than those
of almost any other Western
country or are just many
more years or life imprisonment
or these three strikes
and you're out laws, which
other countries just don't have.
So we end up with much
greater proportion
of our population in prison.
So I think since 1980, we've
put almost 15 million people
in prison in this country
as separate individuals,
not people going back for a
second time, so 15 million.
And it's almost 10
million children
who, at some point
in their lives,
have had a parent in prison.
Since we know that
that tends to create
more crime and more criminals,
that's not a good solution.
Specifically, I'm not sure which
alternative you're looking at.
AUDIENCE: I don't have
experience with this myself.
But my wife was--
She used to be a judge in
France and working specifically
with inmates.
It's a special judge
that in France handles
parole and alternatives
to prison and also people
going out of prison.
And so there are alternatives,
at least in France.
We have alternatives,
like electronic bracelets
or anklets, the possibility to
work outside and sleep in jail,
and for minor offenses,
well, things like community
work and so on.
FOX BUTTERFIELD: So you've
just given a very good answer
as to what we're missing.
As far as I know, we don't
have people like that.
We don't have a judge
who watches over
people who are
released from prison
and provides
alternatives for them.
It doesn't exist.
We want to lock
people up, which is
why we have, by far,
the world's largest
proportion of our population
in jail or prison.
So you're describing
something that
would be very nice to
have in this country.
But we don't have it.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's not
all rosy in France itself.
I mean, prisons are over
capacity by a factor of two.
And, of course, nobody
will vote for more money
to get people into prison.
So last time there was
a right-wing government
that added more stricter
laws, like three strikes
and you're out and so on.
What they did is
that, simply, instead
of commuting all sentences
under a year into alternatives,
they started commuting all
sentences under two years
into alternatives just out
of lack of space in prisons.
Maybe it was a good thing.
I don't know.
FOX BUTTERFIELD: Well I mean,
that's a much more enlightened
and progressive
system than we have,
is we go for the heavy
duty stuff very quickly.
We don't have
enough alternatives.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for presenting today.
FOX BUTTERFIELD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]